how's it going bros my name is P we have
another update on the main man the man
of thickness the man without a neck edy
himself in the last episode to catch the
guys up ed went to the Philippines to
meet his 90-day fiance am i what you
expected do you like
despite edy lying that he doesn't want
to get kids and he's gonna get a
vasectomy that's seriously like does she
want more kids did she tell you that or
not well I don't want to tell her this
but I want to get like nipped he lied
about his height I don't know what else
he lied about I don't remember he still
doesn't trust his fiancee brooch and
thinks it's all a scam her sister texted
me the other night
she basically said you know I need help
my store is gonna close and despite
looking like edy does yo swans rose to
look a certain way and wanted to leave
the family house of rose because it was
not up to his standards is that a
chicken is that a chicken first I would
I read some comments from last episode
as well he looked like he escaped from
Club Penguin before this Oh God the
comments I wrote let's see I didn't say
it I didn't say it I love how she
preferred to shame her legs than kiss
him true it looks like he's cut least
shrugging his shoulders all right that's
just mean I did not like that come on
mad respect for the cameraman who take
it all seriously fair enough fair enough
all right let's get into the new videos
we now have a conclusion of what happens
with Rosa Ned what's gonna happen I
can't wait this is a restaurant and a
big edit rights protected the hotel and
told them I want the most romantic table
in this resort and my hope is that for a
rose and I to grow close that's romantic
I mean having that guy in the background
what you grow closer together and just
relax and just kind of be with each
other all right
maybe there's hope I just wanna take
this in right now just be with you Hey
look at that any how beautiful you look
tonight
here you'll be beauty I'll be the Beast
he knows he knows you've been happy I
want my life see usually with these
TLC's there's at least from what I've
seen there's always like the gold digger
fiancee but for once or at least when I
see this I believe her I believe that
she actually genuinely wants a
relationship with this monstrosity and
it's so weird to see how he's doubting
and just completely ruining it basically
I wish that posed to me this night oh
wow oh you're happy yes of course that's
a bit too soon okay maybe not the main
reason why I wanted to come here with
you was for us to really understand our
feelings so Rose where does your dad
live yeah oh my god
the main reason we are here is not that
I don't want to sleep next to pigs you
know it is reality TV they have all this
scripted out there locations and all
that you have to understand it's not
like Edie Edie made a plan for all of
this but still come on what you want I
want someone that loves me they won't
ever leave me that respects me do you
want that with me do you want someone
that doesn't cheat sheet on you ed oh
sorry
Eddy cheated I forgot about that that's
right he doesn't trust her but he's the
one that cheated in the past marriage
wait whoa
oh how awkward was that edited or
explained do you want that with me Edie
answer please no I mean I think so but
I'm
I'm not 100% sure what's holding you
back yet
what is it I love rose but there's one
thing that's holding me back oh okay and
that is whether or not Rose was involved
with her sister asking me for money why
couldn't you just say that instead of
going I don't know if I can love you or
whatever you said why not just tell her
hey your sister reached out asking me
for money I felt a bit uncomfortable by
that did you know about this it
shouldn't be that hard at it shouldn't
be so hard
God so dramatic because I can I explain
after dinner can we eat first and I'll
explain no that's a terrible idea
oh thank you that's a big mistake Amy no
was there any mail NetID come on explain
me it's about to get juicy here we go I
heard because I think you're not to see
my love you don't see the love ed come
on it's right there I want to hear my
side of that story I heard so much
because you think like my I like my like
my sister
you want your money not with love but I
don't want your money
how much money can you have anyway it's
just a photographer come on isn't sure
if you were involved but you're telling
me you you're not yeah okay I believe
maybe he married raishin the last
relationship okay good your sister made
me doubt you but no more okay good yeah
I am one percent sure that you're being
honest promise I promise
I just wants to resolve this so he can
eat his dinner I'm kidding I'm joking
what the honey's the relationship is
good yes yes yes he says yes for
speaking the Rose lying I am 100% sure
in my heart that she's not involved just
by the way she reacted I'm feeling like
I can completely trust rose but I don't
trust your sister so what are we gonna
do about your sister tell her about this
all right you guys I get a favor
but can you and I speak to her together
it's important to me okay I want to see
that III agree ed let's do that
I thought that makes you start together
okay
I'm relieved I'm angry that my sister a
little bit because you want behind my
back I know Maria struggling on money
right now but I don't want money I love
him and I want to be a wife and our
relationship I know I know
oh my god here I'm thinking we're in a
good place and now she brings up having
more children but I've been planning a
game of sight that baby I don't know how
to tell her well you may am you maybe
should have told her before just like a
little sooner you know I don't know what
kind of conversations you've had but I
don't want more kids she fought is she
found a loophole so she doesn't have to
kiss him just just just just get it
monkey steals big Ed's banana can't wait
sorry what just happen let me smack you
what sounds does she make Wow
classic you too vlogging right here
really likes Matt I'm really excited
that's why she like said same shape oh
my god that's beautiful
are there monkeys in the trees there our
song
he's asking because if they're in the
trees he can't see them he can't you
can't bend his neck the monkeys in the
trees okay good
Eddie's relieved there's another monkey
over there come on so stage there's no
way you would they would tell you before
don't leave stuff out them the monkeys
can grab it especially not bags of food
like that come on it's almost like if we
have 30 TVs fake what cringe what the
hell fake Jesus was that Roast of the
comedy chief says these weren't the cute
monkeys that I was expecting monkeys
he's setting it up instead staring at me
with my pants it looked like he's
constantly sucking his pants that's like
that's the face and posture you want the
wood oh my god oh my god oh my god he
just took my banana but you don't want
monkey I know I think this is funny this
is a metaphor for the upcoming kid
debate or discussion he doesn't want the
monkey but she loved monkey she liked
monkey I like monkey a lot monkey I know
like
don't be scared I don't know he would
attack me I'm terrified I'm worried
about getting bit or scratched I don't
like the monkeys anymore I don't like
him I told you it's a metaphor okay
let's go that's the look of love right
there can see getting their eyes it's
sparkles damn that shape bro that's like
Alex Jones shaped with the hair gotta be
on those pills he finally revealed to
Rose that I want to have a vasectomy and
I don't want any more kids
oh no she was gone she just saw me
shirtless further why am I so mean I
don't know he's so evil he's not evil
he's just really flawed he's just a very
flawed person inside and out she's not
answering my texts and she's not
answering my phone calls I looked all
around the hotel but she's nowhere to be
seen I don't know where she is
she's in the trees that's why she knows
his biggest weakness she's just on the
second floor okay all right I'm really
confused
and I'm sad do you do you think girls
that see this are gonna reach out
communication after they watch this and
marry me you know so it was really more
about me trying to figure out for myself
was Rose the one that I wanted but now
it's kind of you know now it's a 180 now
it's rose really sorting out for herself
whether or not she wants to be with me
what there's two people in a
relationship what she has her own
feelings in thought I understand this
must come as a shock too big end he's
never been rejected in his life come on
[Music]
this is so sad I'm crying hanky if Ed
and Rose can make it then there's hope
for no one no one hey continues Rose
Rose goes off damn oh here comes she
comes
oh she does not look happy
Judah's oh look at me at all I woke up
me every day morning and I want the
thing but you said yesterday all right I
want to be alone there dude he looks
straight up like a mafia guy here and
what happened peace
so for now I'm I not feel good okay not
feel good about having kids and want
kids I want it because that's my thing
that's our dream
disappointed many times a one baby why
you not tell me the truth you not want a
baby
why yeah what do you mean I'm what what
do you mean what what why that's is that
a thing
what what do you say me first before you
come here mmm-hmm gosh this is such
trash TV because I'm 54 years old I
don't want more kids why you're not
telling me that's good why you not me
first untapping oh my god tell me right
now yesterday why you not tell me you
because before you come here I should
have been more truthful I should have
may I apologize I should have said look
I don't want more kids Rose I apologize
come on what what's the matter with you
but I wanted to get to know you I wanted
you to get to know me to make sure that
we are competitive my look at me you
want more of these you're on one of
these things running around trust me
compatible Oh actually she had a
daughter that looked surprisingly nice
so who knows there's there's that face
again
nice never say then there's the face of
love right there to see who I I know who
you are I think she sees exactly who is
Oh first night to me about I yeah yeah
yeah you want oh give me an STD test
right you know about your crush and so
in this appointment because you always
me yeah what what you saying sister I
think you're you think me like my sister
same thing I want your money not you
you give me feel a little bit personally
I think you're not lovely I'm done no no
okay Oh God Oh guys the next this is the
last video and the title I mean it's
gonna shock you to the core Rose ditches
Edie this is your behavior because you
another see another girl and I think you
give her again what you hurt me yeah
alright so you think I'm bad and just
I'm a bad person okay yeah
come on seriously so childish to just
walk away as well when you think I'm a
bad person just because I do all this
bad things work good I pause for us
don't settle for a man like that no way
no way I feel like girls think they can
fix guys a lot at at times do
just dump all right it ain't worth it
a guy like that is always gonna be like
that unless he finds himself I don't
know
it ain't worth your time 18 hurt and sad
because it not accepted he own mistake
yeah he just walked away I miss my son
because I leave him but or it in I'm
inside I daunted this relationship good
good exactly when Ed and I met online
I liked it because he give me respect
but after I meet the person I realized
who is a true IDI right now
Amit micro key in the future sorry and
you're not a king anymore you're just
the Beast is just a beast
oh no goodbye yeah I just I don't know
I'm just I can't hear her anymore it
just hurt it just it hurts me too much
what I mean I'm shocked
I waited 28 years you know to find love
again maybe she just needs time no I
need to let her calm down
do not whistle in again it you need to
fix herself first come on
[Music]
all right is that the end that's the end
ladies and gentlemen
hopefully I actually don't want any more
of this I know they're like everyone's
favorite couple of this TLC channel
stuff it is a reality TV show at the end
of the day and a lot of it is set up at
it I don't think ed is the worst person
on the planet but he is obviously
heavily flawed and I think settling for
a guy that acts that in lies especially
you don't want to do that so good on
Rush good on you and good on good on
roasts and so should you as well that's
it for this video if you enjoyed gently
hit the like button subscribe I upload
every day almost we got new merch
Jojo very nice if you're interested and
think I'm live streaming today you guys
check that out it might be too late
actually never mind see you tomorrow hey
dope in a world where science knows no
boundaries travel to land where no tuber
has been and explore never-before-seen
landscapes
[Music]
beings that are extinct meet Mayan
actors ancestors who collect ancient
items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create
you